사람이 많은 곳에 낚싯대를 넣차
영심하겠습니다. 이게 지금 제가 봤을
때는 오늘도 얘기했어요. 제가
고객분한테 무조건 사람 많은데 낚싯대
넣어야 된다. 괜히 막 딴데 갔다가
나중에 건물도 안 팔리고 임대도 안
되고 내가 산 금액보다 더 싸게 파는
경우도 많거든요. 무엇보다 잘 안
팔려요. 오늘도 제가 그 얘기를
했는데 어 정말 명심하셨으면
좋겠습니다. 그리고 개꿀 직업이지 뭔
극한 직업이야 이렇게 했는데이 본인이
해보세요. 이게
[음악]
지금 네. 안녕하세요. 오늘은 그동안
밀려 있었던 어 댓글 읽기를 좀 해
보겠습니다. 제가 좀 추여서 정리를
해 봤는데 바로 한번 읽어
보겠습니다. 어 두바이나 해외 부동산
투자도 서비스 하시나요? 저희가
본격적으로 하진 않지만 현지에서 한
여덟 분 정도 만났는데 가장 신뢰가
있을 만한 분을 소개시켜 드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 회사로 연락
주시면 상담이 가능할 것 같고.
그리고 송파구 방이동 좀 진단해
주세요. 잠실력이 26년 만에 승하차
인원이 강남역을 뛰어넘어서 어 1위가
됐다고 하는데 그쪽에 건물들 매수해도
괜찮은지 상권 분석 좀 해 주세요.
일단 거기도 한번 저희가 빌사남미
간단 한번 찍어 보긴 할 텐데 근데
여러분들이 아셔야 될게 잠실력에
오시는 분들은 거기 상권을
이용하기보다는 교통 때문에 많이
오거든요. 저기 남양주나 강북에
사시는 분들 만날 때 저기 잠실력
쪽에서 많이 만나더라고요. 그리고
잠실력에서 만나도 방이동까지 가진
않고 대부분 다 롯데 타워 어
그쪽으로 좀 많이 가는 거
같더라고요. 그래서 제가 봤을 때는
방이동 상권으로 물론 가는 사람도
있겠지만 대부분 다 이제 로데타워를
이용하는 이용객이지 않을까 이런
생각을 하게 됩니다. 올해 악구정
로데오는 어떻게 전망하시나요? 최근에
살짝 좀 주춤하긴 했는데 젊은
세대들이 좋아할 만한 그런 브랜드들이
최근에 또 많이 들어가고 있어서 좀
한동안은 좀 계속 괜찮지 않을까 이런
생각을 하고 있습니다. 어, 그리고
좀 저렴한 2, 30억대 빌딩인데
앞으로 유명한 빌딩 지역이 어딘지
궁금합니다. 100억 이상 빌딩들만
보다 보니 너무 넘사벽이라 저렴한
가격대의 빌딩 상권 지역들도 좀 보고
싶네요. 조회수도 잘 나오지
않을까요?가 가주세요. 빌산합니다.
저희가 한번 프로젝트를 만들어서 뭐
제가 생각하는 2, 30억대 빌딩
사기 좋은 동네. 서울시 내에서이
정도 금액대 살 만한 데가 좀 몇
군데 없거든요. 한번 다음의 특집으로
그런 지역을 한번 제가 촬영해 보도록
하겠습니다. 그리고 집 한 채는
있는데 형 뭐 30억 현금이 있으면
빌딩일까요? 반포 아파트일까요? 일단
집이 있다라고 하면 어 저는 뭐 빌딩
투자 고려해 봐도 좋을 거 같고 근데
만약에 집이 없었다면 저는 무조건
반포 아파트가 맞습니다. 일단 1가고
1주택이 세금 혜택도 좋고 이제
거주에 대한 그런 것도 있기 때문에
만약에 집이 없었다면 무조건 반포
아파트인데 만약에 집이 있다라고
하시니까 어 빌딩 투자도 고려해 볼
수 있을 것 같고 어 만약에 현금
30억이면 저는 대출 감당이 만약에
가능하다라고 하면은 뭐 6 70억 그
이상도 빌딩을 살 수는 있지만 적정
수준의 뭐 빌딩 가격은 한 뭐 60억
내외 뭐이 정도가 딱 투자하기 좋은
금액대라고 생각을 합니다. 그리고
개꿀 직업이지 뭔 극한 직업이야
이렇게 했는데 본인이 해 보세요.
이게 지금 냉과 운탕을 왔다 갔다
하고 계약을 했다 그랬다가 안 하기도
하고 그 와중에 수많은 브리핑을
하거든요. 그러면서 진짜 될까 말까
하는 경우도 많고 실질적으로 계약이
돼야지 뭔가 수익이 발생되는 건데
이게 정말 되기도 쉽지 않고 되고
나서도 해야 될 일들이 되게 많아요.
단순하게 이제 집을 보여주고 계약서만
쓰면 그냥 끝나는 거라고 생각을 할
줄 아는데 실질적으로 파고 들어가
보면 생각보다 되게 할게 많다. 어
이렇게 생각해 주시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 사람이 많은 곳에 낚싯대를
넣차 명심하겠습니다. 이게 지금 제가
봤을 때는 오늘도 얘기했어요. 제가
고객분한테 무조건 사람 많은데 낚싯
때 넣어야 된다. 괜히 막 딴데
갔다가 나중에 건물도 안 팔리고
임대도 안 되고 내가 산 금액보다 더
싸게 파는 경우도 많거든요. 그
무엇보다 잘 안 팔려요 건물이.
오늘도 제가 그 얘기를 했는데 어
정말 명심하셨으면 좋겠습니다. 뭐
가격이 싸고 뭐 임대 수익률이 많이
나와서 뭐 매각의 투자 하는게 뭐 더
좋을 수 있다라고 생각할 수 있는데
제가 뭐 지금까지 중기업 하면서
느꼈던 점은 무조건 팔리는데만
팔린다. 그리고 가격이 오르는데만
오르고 앞으로 더 그렇게 될 것이라고
저는 생각을 합니다. 그 200억짜리
건물을 매입하려면 시드를 얼마나
준비해야 하나요? 법인으로 사냐,
개인으로 사냐에 따라 다르긴 하는데
그래도 뭐 대출이나 뭐 취득세 이런
거 감안하면은 100억 정도. 어,
그리고 만약에 재무재표가 괜찮고
만약에 풀 대출이 나온다라고 하면은
현금이 진짜 뭐 한 5, 60억,
70억 이렇게도 살 수는 있는데
그렇게 됐을 때는 너무 부담이 크기
때문에 그래도 한 뭐 80에서
100억은 가지고 있어야지 어, 살
수 있지 않나 그렇게 생각을 합니다.
뭐 요즘에 금리가 좀 내려가긴 했지만
그래도 대출 비율이 그렇게 높게 받는
걸 좀 권하진 않거든요. 또 어떤
상황이 벌어질지 모르고 특히 요즘
같은 때는 임대가 쉽지 않기 때문에
그런 것까지 감안하면 저는 한 50%
정도가 좀 안정권이라고 생각을
합니다. 그리고 내가 진짜 막 건물
다 공실라도 내 다른 수입으로 그걸
메꿀 수 있다라고 하면 그 이상도
생각해 볼 수 있는데 저는 딱 적정
수준은 그냥 건물에서 나온 임대
수익을 어떻게 하겠다라고 하면은 한
50% 정도까지가 제일 안전하지 않나
이렇게 생각을 합니다. 네. 그래서
오랜만에 댓글 읽기를 좀 해 봤고요.
몇 년만이에요? 이고 지금 거의 한
3, 4년 된 거 같은데. 어, 제가
이것도 한번 좀 정기적으로 한번 댓글
모아다가 촬영을 좀 해보도록
하겠습니다. 그래서 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하고요. 다음 시간에 뵙도록
하겠습니다. 습니다.
[음악]